today a group of Republicans big group
of Republicans burst into a closed
hearing room to stop a woman from
testifying against President Trump yeah
yeah there was an awkward moment when
the Republicans said hey you're not
Melania
this is a crowd that's just hearing
about this happening underneath usually
I like the crowd to know what happened
right right no this is true for five
hours today Republicans block someone
from saying damaging things about
President Trump yeah yeah they left
after they realized they could be there
the rest of their lives these things
take time
no I am very thrilled because we have an
amazing show tonight we've we demand to
be a part of these proceedings sorry who
are you and what's this all about well
as representatives of the Republican
representatives rather the United States
Congress it is our god-given right to
know exactly what's going on here and
we're not leaving until we find out okay
but you don't have to storm in here okay
you can just get tickets like everyone
else it's a it's a talk show
oh just we have a constitutional right
to know exactly who is on tonight's show
yeah yeah yeah it's Tim Robbins oh okay
good from from Shawshank Redemption
yes yes ah Sanford
well mate well maybe we have some
questions for Tim Rami okay well what
like like what what are your questions
okay well like what what happened after
Tim Robbins and Morgan Freeman met up at
that boat at the end of Shawshank yeah
did they start a boat rental business or
something like yeah yeah that's what
he's saying
if Andy Dufresne and red opened up a
successful boat rental B I don't know
you'd have to ask him I'm sure it's no
big deal
oh well then why is all this happening
behind closed doors out of public view
what are you hiding
I'm not hiding anything it's behind
closed doors to keep the noise out it's
a sound stage every TV show does that we
do it Alan does it down the street whoa
you said Ellen does she tape on this lot
Ellen DeGeneres yeah she takes these two
stages over
[Applause]
you